[Music]
and extras [ __ ] news oh damn extra extra
action you submitted by coffee and
cocaine
oh look imagine that dude know what a
really good day feels really productive
sounds like a Wall Street energy bar I
don't want to do any of those things
hyper focus here's a look inside the
uniquely flooded cafe in Vietnam that's
pretty tight if you like like these
underwater be flooded no let's have a
pact it's probably girls in the key
probably got flooded like they had a
monsoon in an actual flooded cab it's
not like the OSI cafes where the girls
are in bikinis so there's like this
novelty thing to it right it's flooded
but oh it's really funny
Oh like all the tables are all [ __ ] up
there's mud everywhere is water [ __ ]
up no you know how you can go like cat
cafe yeah yeah you can go to flood cafes
you can go to this cafe where the
there's two floors that are flooded with
hundreds of fish wait two floors is
upstairs yep
although it's between the floor huh or
weed you're stepping on fish yeah you're
stepping on fish and then they kind of
eat your pedicure it's not as crazy
that's pretty tight there's one floor
with small fish in another floor with
what a few sprigs yeah that's always
thinking too like you don't want to
spill any hey what if you accidentally
step on one what if you accidentally
slip they should be stepped on if they
can't swim fast maybe they make you sign
a waiver before you walk in I don't
think they'd sue in Vietnam nah yeah
they're just like [ __ ] lost another one
what if the water gets infected it's
like a little clip damn that's great oh
this guy's a Vietnamese vlogger Lam vlog
oh yeah
Vietnam yeah pretty cool what that place
could all up in these poor fishes are
[ __ ] screaming every [ __ ] second a
lot of people they're hating they don't
know where to run yet a lot of these
people are saying like why would you
stress out these fish just for
entertainment yeah like it's so [ __ ]
up fish do get really stressed out but I
mean what if one dies and it's just
floating them if they get really
stressed out then they just pass away
exactly that's all they really know they
are getting stressed out cuz it all
these fish are dying and it looks like a
- yeah they're trying to like run away
from everything yeah because all those
kids are probably trying to touch them
grab them [ __ ] with them all day yeah
cuz I got fish tanks aquariums fish
tanks you tell you not to like bang on
the I love the puffer fish they just
fall you're yeah I try to scare people
your finger yeah I look like they're
smiling so like I like your finger I
love those what they're all trying to
kill you and [ __ ] [ __ ] you death by
puffer fish sure I'll go out that way
it's funny cuz they're so fat with the
smallest little food
like there's salt water right I think so
yeah I said that had a saltwater tank
and it was freaking huge he had a whole
bunch of exotic fish and I we had a
pufferfish saw lucky I didn't know that
they followed your hand I never looked
at it we look really smart I don't they
look like little dog fish that want to
play with you but you're a cat person so
you don't care about it I like all
animals Gio
I like the petting thing at the aquarium
the [ __ ] you could pick up the stars
and [ __ ] the starfish yeah those don't
get stressed I know that's well you
probably do cuz like Finding Nemo
I mean finding dory was pretty rough me
that [ __ ] look like a like a chase dude
imagine we're just shown here and then
some giant was just like that's what I
think about for spiders like when you
kill a spider
I don't kill spiders but you know like
with the tissue it's like you're just
chilling in your home that you just made
and this huge tissue comes at you you
think yeah a lot of people don't they're
not really happy about this cat face
it's called a mix coffee and it's the
brainchild of this 23 year old who
wanted to take the concept of animal
cafes to a whole new level experience
the world that's gonna grow so
everyone's feet from the outside and
bacteria in the water intro he pumps the
water like it goes through the
filtration system twice so it's
constantly kept clean but the only thing
is that he's having trouble with
handling is the fish going through a lot
of stress so a lot of people bring their
family is like this is for families
mainly like little kids yeah anything
that they've had to ask some families to
leave because these kids will run after
the fish too right of course
and the parents won't do anything about
it that's why they'll ask them to leave
because if the parents are at least
trying to like control their kids and
that's fine but yeah they're not allowed
to run in there that's the first thing I
would have thought of yeah Sam there's
like cuz that's the first thing I would
have an adult as yeah as a child I want
to just chase and grab the fish and I
mean what do kids do when they go to the
rivers they try to catch all the
creatures right or is that just me no
right now there used to be tons of frogs
in our yeah catch them I'm gonna get a
creek yeah we would try to catch the
crawfish the frogs the tadpoles all that
[ __ ] we would spend hours doing that no
you don't even have to be there's a
there's a creek and um right by that
Puente Hills Mall there's like a park
with a little creek and then like their
dough with little tap holes in there a
little crawfish whatever it was fun or
when you go fishing like there's always
like there's like rock cats what's a
rock on the jetty you know like where
those big rocks are where people fish
and you can climb in and there's like
stray cats that live in there yeah any
we try to get like fish food and bait
them so they would come out not to catch
them but we wanted a pet um but they
would never get too close or like
there'll be little crabs that will come
out and we would see if like you would
hurt if we if we put our finger down and
then they pinched this really what did
you do did you get did anyone take you
fishing and all that stuff I do go
fishing a couple of times but don't you
get bored when you're fishing and then
there's like nothing to do so you start
[ __ ] with [ __ ] well what I would do
oh you're on a boat no we would honor
those pier like with the rock pier
things by the beach and then it's like
well my stepdad was fishing I'd be
jumping I'd be like I have this game in
my head or like oh my god I'm about to
die and I have to like jump on each Rock
to like not die Oh animals like that
though one time I got really bored
fishing and then my my uncle had this
like fish string right and I put a hook
on and all that and I got some bait and
I just started putting it down the rock
holes and in something bit so I thought
it was a crab and I pulled it out and it
was this nasty long eel you know
and I just threw it over there it was
just wiggling so gross
yeah they're so ugly he got so pissed
he's like why are you gonna leave that
yield they're like and I was like I
don't want to touch it and he goes well
I'm not gonna let you use the towel and
if those are for my fish and I'm like so
you made me grab the fish with my bare
hands
it's wiggling yeah and then I couldn't
get the hook out right so then you know
those things have gnarly teeth those
much pretty nasty but I had to just get
it from like the neck like this who were
you with that did Electrify my uncle
yeah so they cuz he was like you gotta
[ __ ] clean it up now cuz it's you get
you got the fish right and then so I
couldn't get the hook out with my hand
cuz the big teeth and [ __ ] so then I got
pliers I pulled it out and I've had been
chucked that full back in the water and
my hands were full of you'll see some
girls was a sharp like the like they I
don't know like spikes it have no it was
really slippery and nasty feeling like I
wasn't that you don't really die did you
girl this flame off it's so gross yeah
yeah fuels are so gross-looking who do
you guys visit they know oh [ __ ] animals
like that it makes me sad like when we
were in Japan and then we went to that
owl cafe like yeah it was cool to like
experience these owls or whatever the
livelong gonna get views you know no no
it was just nice to see that they were
just kind of tied up and they can fly oh
I'm like I never want to do this they
say that the island
by them let him fly around at night
though or something yeah they said that
any they come back that's what they tell
about inside oh but then how do they
catch a man whatever I don't know I'd
like to picture the animals in captivity
like I pictured them getting eaten by
another one so I'm like yes safer here
it's kind of like this like a like a
stray dog like it's you're safer in my
house dude we do like every time I go to
downtown LA to like the alleys I don't
know if you guys have been but there's
like hella random [ __ ] all the [ __ ] my
sanity right and so they have like fish
and bags they have Turtles and like
these set of things and I just see them
or like little bunnies and I'm just like
do you guys see my like take care of
them do you guys feed them I just wish I
could take them off but then you know
it's a lot I don't know how many of you
are into male culture but there's like
new thing came out which was like in
Japan or something like that where like
they were having like ants inside up
there we did it we did that here yeah
and then like the answer just moving I'm
like [ __ ] - you really need a [ __ ]
aunt and you're now like being glitter
like so many other nothing things are
put on your now that's pretty that's
what you want
you didn't collect stuff in your
backyard like slugs and snails and oh
yeah probably poley friends yeah but
they were still in your backyard you
didn't put it in like a job um I would
pull like dirt and like grass and then I
would make like my old Nicole yeah I
didn't know they would die until they
died like I had like a big-ass blast jar
and I had like an entire [ __ ] family
of like ladybugs in there and I put like
you know like twigs and plants and stuff
and just things that I think would help
them all live and then they all end up
frying in the side a lizard I like
cotton and I put it in this bowl and I
like wanted to play with him later
but I didn't want to bring him inside
cause I'm like he needs the Sun and um
and then we went to the pool and then I
came back and he was completely fried I
felt so bad I was like so heartbroken I
[ __ ] steamed cooked a caterpillar on
it like you know those fancy
caterpillars are like multiple crazy
colors so I in the morning I found when
I was like oh [ __ ] so I got a jar
I put that modifier I capped it and I
was like that's enough air cuz it's
small
I didn't poke holes or anything put it
in my backpack right because I wanted to
show everyone and I was like oh [ __ ] it
was a hot day I totally forgot it was
toward the end of the day yeah and then
I opened it and I was like ah man
and that fool look like a [ __ ] egg
roll just like like a rolling around and
I was like I wanted to show everyone and
my teachers like it's dead Joseph and
I'm like no I think he's sleeping
[Laughter]
[Music]